écoutez cameron quand il dans ses
premières années de premier ministre
était très critique sur l'europe et il a
essayé de muter en saint-georges
défendant la grande bretagne en europe
dans les dernières semaines donc ça ne
pouvait pas marcher boris johnson était
mère d'une que d'une grande ville une
capitale européenne dont il veut lancer
la capitale européenne mince nous sommes
européens et il lui se mue en rappelant
qu'il a été journaliste et qui a été
chargé des affaires européennes puissent
faire était fonctionnaire européen et
lui se mue en anti europe et enfin on
voit bien qu'on est dans un jeu de dupes
le plus total alors maintenant quelles
vont être les conséquences de sa bien ça
signifie qu'on pratique cameron restera
dans l'histoire comme celui qui a sorti
la grande bretagne et qu'il a isolé et
qui fait courir la grande à la
grande-bretagne à sa sauce
ces deux grandes nations européennes le
risque simplement de dissolution avec
peut-être la disparition de l'ecosse
avec peut-être le détachement de
l'irlande parce que la question de la
frontière entre la république d'irlande
et la grande bretagne de nouveau se pose
alors qu'elles étaient résolus plus
nombreuses années donc dans l'histoire
je ne suis pas certain qu'avec david
cameron restent eux restera un grand
premier ministre